madame galves munos vous vous en avait
déjà parlé mais donc sur le front
économique les femmes trinquent les sont
les premières à trinquer durant la
pandémie qu'elles sont plus facilement
licenciés et c'est pas forcément elles
qui vont être réintégrés en premier
qu'est ce que l'europe peut apporter
comme réponse pour ces femmes qui sont
mis sur le banc de la société économique
et du monde de l'emploi à cause de la
pandémie
je pense que l'un portait encore
beaucoup des critiques la portaient les
chouquettes et satinée instrument
important pour maintenir les deux le
travail l'emploi des personnes soient
des hommes et des femmes mais et on doit
savoir que les plans d'aidé récupération
ils sont surtout pensés pour la france
et sion écologique et la transition
digital et ce sont des secteurs
majoritairement avec des plots masculin
donc et il faut et mettre au même niveau
une troisième transition la transition
vers et hacker dit on peut dire en
anglais que c'est plus facile d
d'entendre et les maîtres au même le
autrement on ça va passer commande et
chris impressionnant donc il faut faire
un petit peu encore pas seulement la
transversalité par sono le bouger mais
il faut le faire avec des syndicats
terre que l'on peut suivre aussi dans
les plans national de récupération
transformationnel silence un
d'indicateurs féministe en quelque sorte
que vous nous préconisé
[Musique]